Elizabeth is with us in Dallas Texas hi
Elizabeth how are you how can I help
oh so a couple weeks oh my husband found
you and YouTube and he's been listening
to you religiously and doing everything
you say and I'm pretty excited because
we're in a lot of debt
we're only 24 years old and we make
pretty good money he makes mechanics I
make flag hours but it's a pretty decent
amount to be in the debt that were in
right now yeah so what's your household
your household income uh here's about 70
to 80 but it's not steady because of
swag hours and mine is about 30 to 40
okay so you're making like 1 to 110 all
right and how much debt do you have so
we had a lot of credit cards I just like
because we got a house we couldn't
afford and we plan on like letting
people borrowing money from other people
and then getting credit cards and I know
characters are bad so car you have
20,000 20,000 that's been is it all
along
no we got a loan that was a lower
interest rate to pay off how much how
much do you own your cars is that in the
1,000 what is that part of the 20,000 no
the 11 on your car that's 31 okay and
how much that's doing no student loans I
paid all cool off and how much is your
house payment 1,300 okay
that's doable once we get you on a
budget
yeah alright so how can I help so we we
kind of try to figure it out we put our
lowest like the lowest thing we have to
pay off first and the highest thing and
then we got my husband a budget because
he was spending $1,000 I'm like
airsofting going houses trends and then
another thousand dollars I'm like lunch
money and stuff like that and another
thousand dollars I'm just going out
smoothies and stuff like that so it was
about three thousand dollars of extra
stuff not including any pills or
anything and now we we went down and I
I'm beating him 200
joining dollars a week for food not just
food cuz I'm making you lunch just for
extra stuff or whatever he needs
yeah what can I help you with today so
he doesn't want to set any money now go
to anywhere not do anything because we
work and get out of it which is
understandable but I don't think you'll
be able to do that for the mayor very
long why he I say maybe one day a week
on one wall out to one restaurant why
because we've gone out everything stop
stops so you know I may you make a
hundred and two a hundred and ten
thousand you owe 20 you owe thirty one
thousand dollars you could if you lived
on beans and rice and stayed out of a
restaurant you could be debt-free in a
year and some change maybe 14 months and
so I've known a lot of people over
thirty years that have worked on this
idea and none of them died from not
going to a restaurant but I just think
going from it's just like such extremes
maybe how it going to the movies might
be like for six dollars one day a week
and sort of never going again because if
we never go again I feel like after a
month we're just going to give up on it
I don't think anybody said never yeah we
said for fourteen whole months and we're
just used to going out every weekend
Friday sorry Sunday Mondays and then and
you're broke yeah how's that working for
you
not very well okay so it's time to
change yeah and so the whole idea the
whole idea is if you're kind of new to
this and he's jumped in and he's gone
whole hog I can tell and he's driving
you nuts
okay so but but here's the thing why
don't you guys try something that's
radical for thirty days hold your nose
and see how you do see if you see how
you feel about it because here's the
thing the more radical your your
sacrifice is the more radical your
results and what we teach folks is if
you live like no one else later you can
live and give like no one else now you
are an adult you make a hundred and ten
thousand dollars a year
you can go out to eat or go to a movie
you have the right to make that decision
but you're calling me and asking me how
to best win with money and what I found
is is that if I will just say I'm gonna
do something completely different and
kind of shock the system shock my
emotional system my spiritual system my
family system by completely changing
directions for a short period of time if
you get out of a bunch of debt and you
hate it you can go right back in debt
it's okay I mean you'll be able to do it
though they'll let you get right back in
so the thing is what you've been doing
the way you've been living has caused
you to be where you are the more you
approximate that the closer you continue
to live like you got used to live the
less the more you're gonna look like you
look right now financially and so you've
got to change now does that mean you're
gonna do that the rest of your life no
but what this amounts to is is you guys
have been you've been acting like little
children you just been doing what feels
good and adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good and it's
a maturity thing whether you're 54 24
1484 it's a maturity thing the ability
to delay pleasure for a greater result
is an indication of emotional and
spiritual maturity living like no one
else so later you can live and give like
no one else is hard but it's worth it
now then you've got to decide what you
guys are going to do but the thing
you've got to do is look past the
momentary pain to the greater gain
you've got to look past and say why am i
doing this because that baby I'm hearing
in the background wants a better life I
want to change my family tree why are
you doing this because I'm sick and
tired of making a hundred and ten
thousand dollars a year worth busting my
hump doing side work and being broke so
something's got to give and that's why
your husband he said oh you know he
works on cars I mean he knows if you do
one thing to a car cars not gonna run if
you do another thing the car the car is
gonna run it's a it's you're gonna you
know create the
result you want you control the
controllables and then you decide what
you want to do so that's how you do it
that's exactly how you do it
so I'm gonna put you two through
Financial Peace University and if you'll
go to the class and through the class
together I'm gonna pay for it if you'll
hold on Kelly's gonna pick up then
you'll start to get your hands around
what I'm talking about and it stops
being an argument about going to a
freaking movie and starts being a
decision that changed my life and then
you can decide what do that you want to
do people do all kinds of different
things but this is what we're teaching
and and if your husband is going
completely overboard then you know if
you're in that group in financial peace
some of the people in there I'll talk to
him about that I mean if he's starving
his children or something or he's not
willing to buy clothes for his own
children and that's a problem that's not
what we're talking about but yeah
stopping things that are entertainment
what's going out to eat is entertainment
going to movies entertainment in order
for a short period of time in order to
hit a bigger goal for a noble reason
yeah it's worth it and I do recommend
that living like no one else so later
you can live and give like no one else